[Music]
you know my dad told me last night he
said that you got a full ride to Kansas
we just quit why my father didn't like
me very much and someone told him I was
good at basketball
he paid a lot more attention to me and I
realized it wasn't me that he loved it
was what I could do wasn't a lot of time
earning myself trying to hurt my father
I never pick up a basketball game
[Music]
they need a new coach Jack you're the
first person I thought of the team any
good no fact the last time we made the
playoffs back when you were playing this
whole team ten Kitson wonder why they're
leaving you opens because they don't
think you could hit the ocean from the
beach
heard you're coaching basketball just my
mind off other things
I understand you're trying to motivate
the team but we have a code
like this is not as bad as record we
have to trust each other we have to have
faith
we just want you to be happy again but I
don't want it to
don't underestimate the impact you can
have on
you got this no but just not I'm gonna
hear your voice yes or no yes
you nervous I get it truth is the more
talented than you probably I'd better
coach but I promise you they are not a
better team
they haven't been through what we've
been through they don't know adversity
they don't know what it's like to get
knocked out have to get back up again
is the fight
we can't change the past Jack what we
can do is choose how we move forward
[Music]